[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
toten wird heute möchte ich euch einen
cocktail zeigen
ich habe nämlich gedacht dass wir für
die silvesterparty in paar cocktails
machen
ich werde sie allerdings alkoholfrei
machen aber natürlich könnt ihr da auch
der etwas alkohol rein münchen für
diejenigen die das gerne mit alkohol
mögen das zeigt aber später noch wie wir
und was ihr da mit rein machen könnt und
zwar werde ich heute einen anderen us
cops cocktail machen und ich mag das
ganz gerne wenn man da frische ananas
nimmt weil ich einfach diese 15 seine
liebe ananas ist ja sowieso was ganz
toll ist und auch übrigens um oder fett
verbrennt habe man auch schon lange
anders geht immer
jetzt kenne ich alles ist normal sind
genau das alles gegessen außer andere
und ich möchte euch jetzt eben zeigen
niemand diesen cocktail macht ich sage
euch auch noch die mengenangaben aber
natürlich könnt ihr die variieren und so
machen wir jetzt möchte weil es sich
dann die konsistenz ändert und jeder hat
andere vorlieben ich sage ich jetzt
einfach mal was ich an zutaten benutze
und zwar nehme ich eine andere und es
ist eine schöne süße ananas das erkennt
man daran dass man hier wenn man die
blätter rauszieht dass die dann leicht
abgeben
das ist so ein merkmal das eben die
abermals reif ist könnten wegschmeißen
und außerdem an der farbe also wenn so
eine richtig schöne bräunliche farbe
außenrum hab so ein schönes grün dann
ist die ananas reif
ich nehme dann auch noch ein herr
kokosnuss die müsst ihr nicht zwingend
nehmen
ich finde es nur ganz cool den cocktail
in der kokosnuss zu servieren und
deswegen probiere ich das heute mal auf
dann etwas wählens könnte auch sagen
eben weil es gern etwas peppiger haben
möchte ananassaft da achte ich immer
darauf dass ich 100 prozent saft nehme
das halt noch nicht noch extra zucker
mit drin ist also wir kaufen auch gerne
herrschaft apfelsaft aber immer 100
prozent saft weil man dann einfach den
zusatz zusätzlichen zucker eben
vermeiden kann und stand noch etwas
vanille eis tages nehmt ihr ganz
normales
ich habs jetzt bei uns bei globus
gekauft die dann jeder anderen marke und
ich benutze und ich bin etwas kompost
creme und zwar könnt ihr auch kokosmilch
nehmen aus der dose
ich habe jetzt diese kokos creme zum
ersten mal gekauft und bin da auch
irgendwie ganz gespannt darauf wie die
überhaupt ist da steht zwar gut
schütteln aber ich kann die panik
schütteln weil das eine feste creme ist
als so eine richtig der cocos creme und
starke bereits einfach mal ob das mit
der eben klappt das sind gute zutaten
und ich zeige euch jetzt am besten so
erst einmal wie ich die kokosnuss
aufmachen und zwar steht da auf diesen
kleinen update vom der kokosnuss steht
darauf dass man diese drei löcher
benutzt um eben die kokosnuss
aufzumachen und darf wir brauchen
schraubenzieher und hummer
das ist übrigens mein werkzeug und nicht
das von meinem mann im handwerk ich
mache ich auch gerne mal kann ich auch
mal können zeigen
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal wie die
anders aufgemacht wird wenn es natürlich
so klappt wie es auf dem zettel steht
und zwar steht bei jetzt darf man mit
einem hammer und mit einem
schraubenzieher in diese drei becher
schlagen soll steht dann auch ein
schlitzohr am kreuz ich jetzt einfach
nur im kopf schon sehr denn kräuter sind
etwas kleiner das kann ich besser halten
so lege ich jetzt direkt auf dieses eine
loch und dann rechts dar einzuhämmern
gehypten klaus holen ich mache noch ein
zweites loch da rein
kinder sollten doch bitte nicht arbeite
nachmachen den dazu bitte eure eltern am
besten den papa die mama besitzt dann
nehme ich mir und schüttet da jetzt den
saft rolle spielen da möchte so drauf
und lass raus laufen gut stimmt sagt
stelle man dann zur seite
und jetzt steht da auf diesem zettel
dass man sich eine linie denken soll
also ich erzähle drei löcher und möchte
in dieser hälfte der kokosnuss später
meinen drinks servieren
und jetzt steht hier das was ich hier so
eine linie denken soll
und da jetzt mit dem messerrücken immer
dieser linien draufschlägt
und da steht das dann irgendwann ein
riss entsteht und macht das dann
aufgeregt bin echt gespannt webseite
eines küchenmessers
mein gott es geht nicht
[Musik]
wer das gemacht ihr habt aufgemacht der
morath aufgemacht beste bisher alle froh
dass mit dem trick mit dem drauf klopfen
funktioniert net mein mann hat er ist
jetzt mit gewalt geöffnet und zwar mit
dem messer mit der scharfen seite hier
draufgehauen man kann es aber auch mit
nachdenke aufsägen aber ich finde ich
den trick nicht gestattet
ja und jetzt möchte ich dass hersteller
installieren und nehme deswegen jetzt
noch ein bisschen von dieser von diesem
kokos fleisch hier raus geht auch ganz
guten weg zum kleiner messer ein
bisschen weg schneide
die composites offen ich ausgewählt dank
meinem mann
und falls ihr tipps habt wie ich die
toko ist alleine öffnen kann dann bitte
immer her mit dem tipp da steht doch im
werk zurück dafür dann brauche ich auch
keine man merken und mir werte zwar
gleich den cocktail das installieren
aber ich werde auch danach die kokosnuss
war das ausgetrunken haben natürlich
auch wieder klein mache mit einem hammer
diesmal einfach dass die klein gemacht
wird und dann des längeren kokos fleisch
essen sich wirklich so lecker
ich weiß nicht ob wir jemals fleisch
gegessen habt wenn nicht soll dies auf
jeden fall mal probieren
als nächstes wird die ananas kleinen
gemacht das geht natürlich ganz einfach
im gegensatz zu focus
und zwar habe ich so ein anlass weiter
und das ist eigentlich eine ganz
herkömmliche anders schneider hat aber
zwei dinge einmal für eine kleine aber
feine große und beinahe schon ein
relativ großer anders sieht es darum
wenn ich das jetzt daran halte habe ich
auch warum immer noch in brand der groß
genug ist und das tolle ist dabei wenn
ich diesen anlass leiter benutzt dann
wird die ananas ausgefüllt das heißt ich
kann auch darin main
reservieren ich sage ich das jetzt
einfach mal dieses gerät ist übrigens
von hobbys finde ich echt die haben ganz
tolle durchdachte und richtig handliche
geräte die haben nicht so viele geräte
aber auch echt tolle produkte und wenn
ihr möchtet und wenn ihr euch das
interessiert kann ich gerne versuchen
dass er meinen job aufzunehmen und
staudenbeete anders da oben
abgeschnitten also dieser deckel und
jetzt nehme ich mir diesen anderes
schneitter und zwar der andere hier so
eine markierung ich muss nämlich nicht
immer komplett egal was schneiden
sondern kann hier sehen bei 123 4 bis 10
wenn ich bin heißt es ich habe zehn
scheiben an was jetzt geschnitten und
das geht ganz einfach
diese öffnung hier diese zahnräder
kommen hier auf dem strom also dass hier
in der mittelstraße strom von damals den
wollen die meisten nicht mitessen
aber der hat damals schon vitamine
mister helfen
dann lege ich das jetzt hier schon
richtig drauf dass das richtig mutig ist
so und da könnte im übrigen auch sehen
ob jetzt des von der größe her passt ich
kann es euch mal mit den kleinen
zahnrads zeigen dass man jetzt so ich
weiß nicht was jetzt bessere weil ich
hatte damals ausfüllen will und das
konservieren will ich haben jetzt
umentschieden ich nehme jetzt doch das
kleine wenn ich jetzt die aber das
schreiben essen wollte würde ich jetzt
das große leben mache ich ja mehr
anfahren möchte aber ich möchte jetzt
auch dass die anderen schönen form
behält und die gefäß er gibt mir dann
vielleicht etwas aus werkzeug wie es
geht und jetzt wird es einfach nur
beträgt hier können wir nicht sehen habe
ich jetzt eigene scheiben geschnitten
jetzt nicht weiter zweiter ich habe mir
gedacht ich fahr bis zu achten und
und dann können doch das hier einfach
aussehen und dann ist das eben kurz
lösen und dann habt ihr hier die schönen
anders schreiben und dann könnte hier
den hebel wegnehmen und die anderen
zeugen darunter nehmen so ganz einfach
weshalb er so eine spirale und das
könnte dann auch entscheiden schreiben
und das innere der anderen steht jetzt
übrigens so aus da habe ich jetzt noch
den strom dann werde ich gleich
entfernen
aber ich sehe jetzt auf gehabt dass ich
bis zum boden herunter schon ein
bisschen platz hat das heißt ich kann
jetzt das auch hier wieder dran und
ruhig noch ein paar scheiben schneiden
genau nehme ich mir einfach ein kleines
messer und schneidet den strunk hier weg
und den amas after drin denn benutze ich
gleich einfach für meinen sheikh und
früher hatte ich eigentlich verschlief
rische artern asta weil mir der aufwand
immer viel zu groß wird ihr anderen
auszustehen stücke zu schneiden
er kennt sie noch aus meinem upside down
video da hatte ich den schläger rentner
muss die anderen noch single und in
stücke schneiden
aber seitdem ich eben diese
namensschilder hat vielen das leben
total gut ich kann mir immer frische
anderes kaufen kann die einfach schnell
kurz rausschneiden und essen weil ich
finde einfach dass die anderen das
frisch viel besser schmeckt da ich viel
weniger zucker drin also in dieser geht
zu garten dose und es ist wirklich sehr
schnell gemacht jetzt zeige ich euch
aber natürlich will man in shake macht
das mache ich eben termin können da aber
in jeder anderen küchenmaschinen dann
natürlich auch und hier ist ganz gut
dass ich in der waage mit drin habe aber
wenn ihr eben einen anderen weg benutzt
stellte einfach den mixer auf eine waage
und da gebe ich jetzt ein paar anna loos
stücke rein und zwar so etwa 120km die
thermik sich jetzt einfach mal schnell
und da gebe ich auch ein bisschen kurs
fleisch schreiben wenn ich schon darauf
sie guckt nur dass ich keine schale mit
reis ist so lecker was ihr selbst
aufnehmen könnt sind kokosflocken so
etwa drei es jürgen körner damit dazu
geben
dann kommt da jedes mails mit reigen
etwa 80 milliliter oder 80 gramm dann
etwa 100 gramm anderen aus saft da gebe
ich jetzt erstmal den sagt von hier
betreiben doch dummerweise kommt dann
noch etwas heller 1 manila ist nämlich
auch so etwa 100 kann
wie kann man dem dach von price würfel
da könnte zum beispiel auch ganz gut
ananassaft den einst würfel behälter
geben und einfrieren
dann schmeckt nämlich nur bessere ich
weil wir mais würfeln
findig schmeckt das getränk immer gleich
so wässrig weil er 15 mal aus wasser
besteht aber wenn er eben eiswürfel aus
was macht haben gleich geschmack und ich
gehe jetzt 1 4 esslöffel von dieser
creme mit rein
aber wie gesagt könnte da auch das ethos
kann da auch kokosmilch aus der dose
nehmen
das wird jetzt alles schön und so steht
jetzt bei mir dass shaikh aus also
richtig schön cremig sage ich zeige euch
jetzt also ich werde so ziert
installieren ihr könnt es natürlich auch
direkt in cocktailgläser oder in der
ganz normale long trinkgläser blieben 1
markierte am rhein aus der kokosnuss
kann man das natürlich direkt trinken
gehe ich aus so schön klein
die anderen acht finde ich komme
aufkommen zu zweit rauschtrinken so von
der größe her
ich habe natürlich ganz vergessen dass
man auch natürlich diesen kokos saft
benutzen kann könnt ihr natürlich auch
vorher mit in den städten geben oder ihr
könnt dann einfach so trinken kokos oft
finde ich nämlich auch sehr lecker
falls ihr das ganze natürlich
alkoholisch vahrenholt können wir da
etwas kommt muss liegt rein geben zum
beispiel batida de coco schlägt bestimmt
ganz gut da gibt es einfach so viel rein
wie ihr eben mit obst daneben 40
milliliter sind oder 100 milliliter
müsst ihr dann entscheiden das können da
ganz einfach beim mixen mit dazugeben
und daneben auch so servieren
ich würde jetzt noch in den kühlschrank
geben bis zum servieren ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefällt und dieser
kleine trinkaus dem aus der kokosnuss
und die rezepte gibt natürlich zum
nachlesen auf www.telekom.de und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
fußball
[Musik]
der mann steht jena der kamera und guckt
und die frau muss er arbeiten kannst du
bitte festhalten sein